the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios i'm ryan sickler and
i can't thank you enough for supporting
this show you guys are the die hards and
i know it and i genuinely appreciate
seeing this community grow and grow i
[ __ ] love my job i love this show and
uh man y'all have not let any of us down
so
um if you're new here thank you and
welcome if you've been here hey thank
you as well uh and if you want to save
some money if you're in for the long
haul you sign up for a year get over a
month free it's five bucks a month you
get the honeydew a day early ad free as
well at no additional cost all right if
you or someone you know has that story
that has to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com you don't need
to be a patreon in order to do the show
uh and and the story doesn't need to be
yours it can be someone else's introduce
them that's fine
um
look you know i love highlighting low
lights and i love uh bringing light to
the darkness and and some of the
episodes get really dark and and some
tend to be a little lighter and i'm
hoping uh this one here
ends up being on a little bit of the
ladder side so ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the honeydew with
y'all zach johnson everybody welcome to
the honeydew with the all zach
hey buddy what's happening
uh first of all we were talking before
uh we were recording and you got some
maryland ties to you so how's that now
oh that's uh thanks to my dad he was a
civil engineer for uh he still is and uh
we got shipped up to maryland
oh in like uh 2006 2007 uh right sort of
a recession was happening and that was
kind of the last sort of stronghold that
he could find work and so we ended up
there we had family up there anyway
and uh
finished out high school uh a little bit
of college at uh towson university do
you know where that is that's where i
graduated from you know that's where i
graduated from well you know i i got to
give a shout out to our uh other alma
mater to uh ups hub in baltimore primary
one joe avenue you work
work what year did you work there
uh
2008 2009 2010. okay yeah shout out to
ups baltimore primary one joe avenue
beautiful place i just i just drove by
when i was there um did you yeah man
that's violetsville yep no yeah
dude
right let's jump here we got a lot of
stuff to talk about because um
you sent an email in that i literally
had to write back is this [ __ ] true and
you're like yeah it's true so you did um
your quick response
well when you see [ __ ] like this
your [ __ ] [ __ ] said that your drink
was spiked and your mom tried to [ __ ]
you
yes
zack i mean no offense when i say this
but you look like a guy whose mom would
try to [ __ ] him
well you know all right well before we
get into that story it sounds like
there's some sordid tales that lead up
to this so why don't you take the reigns
okay well
i guess to give that some context i mean
yeah i i i'm from georgia originally i'm
sure you can tell i hear if i say if i
say enough words you'll hear it very
clearly
um
my parents uh were together
uh only for about three years uh dad was
in the military desert storm and
mom was pretty much
just a gold digger from the get-go uh i
mean my dad even admits it now he's like
i should have married her everyone told
me not to
you know at the time she thought she
looked good she was nice they went for
it and it wound up being a complete
[ __ ] the whole way i mean he's
he's off in iraq doing whatever and my
mom's at the military base writing
checks left and right running up debt
uh even to the point to where
you know dad's in a foxhole and he's
getting radio that the provost marshal
wants to talk to him about bad checks
that are getting written in his name and
bouncing left and right no
yeah i mean and that's i think he's told
me that's like the chief of the military
police is looking for him about hey uh
there's a 300 check in your name hey it
bounced we need to talk and that's what
my mom was doing and so my dad gets back
from overseas finds out there's tens of
thousands of dollars in debt i mean and
all she's doing is buying dresses and
shoes and going out with
people you're not not really uh the
right type of people either um
and so
you know long story short with that one
at about age three they split up
are you an only child
by them i am okay uh
with my biological mom and dad it's just
me i've got
two half siblings from my mom with a
different guy okay who
um
let's see
they my two half siblings are
collectively about eight and five years
older than i am okay uh their dad was
married to my mom and then in
1987 came out gay and said we need a
divorce
all right hey you know what and and
that's a chattanooga tennessee so that
was a big of a stretch that was 87.
yeah boy and so that they split but they
stayed close in kind of a weird way so i
guess when it's that sort of an
arrangement it's like i can't be mad at
you that's your heart that's your
feelings yeah let's go from there
um
so i've got those two and my sister uh i
call her my sister whether it's half or
whatever she's just it is we share blood
we're there
she plays uh
a mildly pivotal role in our later story
so
um
so my parents are getting divorced and
it comes out you know my mom's running
around on my dad she's hanging out with
other dudes and the whole thing
and we get into court which i don't
remember much of i mean i i have one
distinct memory of being in the court
annex with my great grandmother and just
sitting on a bench just hanging out
while they're over in the next
courthouse just tearing each other apart
um
and from everything i understand my mom
was just a [ __ ]
you know just
she was i mean to the point that her own
family was testifying against her yeah
in the courtroom like
no no she's
not a good person and uh
i was even told that um
the the judge said that if my two half
siblings were my biological siblings he
would have taken them away from her and
given them to my dad so my dad got full
custody of me okay he did i was gonna
ask yeah but how was how was let me ask
you this even though uh she may be a bad
person how did she treat you is she was
she nice to you though or just
neglectful maybe and all that but was
she abusive in any way like
well i'll put it this way
uh
when i okay so
my dad got full custody of me so my mom
got visitation
every other sunday
and just for sunday afternoon that's all
the judge would allow her and was it
supervised
no
because
because what would happen
would be my mom would come pick me up
sunday
and then drive me
about an hour and a half north into
tennessee with where her family kind of
was drop me off at her mom's house and
then leave directly and go hang out with
some guy the whole afternoon come pick
me back up you're just hanging out with
grandma not mom
one uh no i hung out at her house
grandma ran a convenience store about
three miles away
where
where if we got so you're just being
dropped off oh yeah yeah if we if we got
bored we'd go down there and this is the
kind of convenience store back in the
day the back room had a pool hall
gambling machine smoking the whole thing
and so if we got bored we'd go down
there and she would just tear off
scratchers and let us just sit there on
the counter just winning two dollars a
piece and can i win this no okay
so uh it was that
and that all kind of came to a head when
i was about five and so
this is one of uh
mom's times where she would drop me off
and
sometimes she would stick around
sometimes she wouldn't um just whatever
was on her mind at that time
and
this this it was sometime in the summer
i forgot when
but uh
drop us off she goes doing whatever so
me and my siblings we go in the backyard
and there's a creek running in the back
and so we're hanging out just doing
summertime country things
playing in the creek and whatever and
unbeknownst to me
mosquitoes
are starting to get on me which that's
the south in the summer go figure
but
my mom comes back okay we gotta take you
back home she gets me in the car and i
can tell even by the look at her face
something's like she's she's kind of
giving me this this wild-eyed kind of
look and that's she's like well let's
just get you in the car let you get you
home and i said okay
so i'm in the car
and in the on the ride back which is
again lengthy i'm i'm slowly just kind
of
getting
sweaty and i'm getting kind of woo and
my head starts spinning and i'm not
feeling good
we get to my dad's house
she's there for all of about 30 seconds
she gets out just fast enough to get
around the car get to the door open it
up all right here you go here's your bag
here comes my dad out the door here he
is and then shoves me kind of to my dad
runs back in the car and leaves which i
thought was
weird
and so my dad's kind of like
all right well bye you know don't say
nothing and he looks down at me and his
face just goes white
and i was like
daddy i'm five i'm like my dad are you
okay
and he he doesn't say a word to me he
scoops me up puts me in the car next
thing i know we're at the hospital
and there's he's in we're in the er and
he's doing all this stuff and
we're back in a room finally and the
doctor comes in and they're in there and
they're kind of in a corner talking and
i can't hear and i don't know what's
happening i'm five
and come to find out much later in life
um
what had happened was my mom left us
outside so long
that
mosquitoes just tore me up
uh when they got to when i got me when
my dad finally got me to the hospital
the doctor stopped counting
at 250 mosquito bites holy [ __ ]
yeah and that's that's on a medical
record that's not i can't make that
number up they stopped they literally
said 250 plus and just did a thing
and they were terrified that i had you
know malaria or west nile i don't know
if that was around them but you know
some some disease from mosquitoes like
and i'm getting shots in the butt i'm
getting the full work over
and uh i was sick for
several days just sweaty and the whole
thing i felt like i was in africa or
something but uh
it finally got that straightened out and
so you know two weeks goes by to my
mom's next visit and
she shows up picks me up we go off
this time she stuck with me like we
she was there around engaging the whole
thing
which
at that point i thought that was weird
right different yeah you're here yeah
okay well you know that's fine
and uh i remember on the way back to my
dad's after visitation we stopped at a
kmart
and we went for the blue light special
and they had one of those
lego pirate ships the big you know
thousand piece units that were like a
hundred something bucks bought me one of
those
it was great because i love being you'll
play with them in the you know bath or
whatever and
we got to my dad's house she drops me
off
dad i mean he's out the door he's
waiting for her to show up he comes out
the door
he says all right here's your stuff go
inside i'll be in a minute
i was like okay so i go inside
and the way our kind of house was you'd
come in this sort of door and there's a
big picture window and i kind of looked
out the picture window at them
and my dad
you being a dad myself as well you know
that look you give somebody when you're
you're about to tear them a new one like
you i mean it's a he has that look on
them and he's giving it to my mom and he
he's just i can just see you just red
he's getting furious
oh jesus like okay whatever i'm gonna go
inside like i don't i don't know i don't
want to know
and that was the last time i saw my mom
ever
for
23 years holy [ __ ]
that was it
uh
and and
at the time and i distinctly remember
the next two weeks went by i stood at
the window to watch for her car to come
didn't come
next two weeks didn't come and i was
like
at what point what point do you talk to
your dad about that
uh when i was 18.
so you just looked until you never asked
your dad never said hey she's not coming
or he wasn't sure if she was
well what it uh when i talked to him
when i was 18 um
because you know
in the state of tennessee you know
whoever loses custody has to pay child
support
mom quit paying child support like the
last time she showed up that was last
time she brought a check for child
support so before i was 18 she owed me
like
several hundreds of thousands of dollars
in back child support
and right before i turned 18 i talked to
my dad about it i was like should we go
i mean that's a lot of money that would
put me through college that would do a
lot for me should we go after her and
get this and he's just
she'd go to jail before she'd pay it
and i was like
yeah okay well fine
uh because really at that point he knew
her better than i did you know i was
five when she or four or five when she
quit coming so i was like
okay well forget that and then sort of
let it stew for a minute so dad why did
she quit coming like i just you know
i just kind of let it go because
we on my dad's side of the family we had
such a tight-knit group with like my
aunt and uncles grandparents
great-grandparents we were all like
right there with each other so we didn't
think about it or i didn't think about
it
um and he he finally just like well you
know you say do you remember that day
the last time she showed up i said yeah
he said well
you know i basically went out and told
her that you know i knew i found out
that she was dropping you off and
running off with because should
even sometimes would i mean i do
remember there were some occasions dad
would let her have me for the weekend
but it was here mom buy and go off with
guys for a weekend he's like i know what
you've been doing i know who you've been
running around with i got it
it either a stops
or i'm gonna go to the court and tell
them what's happening and you get no
visitation and you'll never see him
again
your choice
and she made the decision
to not see me
and just ran off and decided she was
going to live her own life and
you know
cross her fingers wish for the best for
me i guess
and how long is that the gap between
that
her leaving and you seeing her again
18 years you said something like that
like 23 23 years yeah i i was close to
like 27 28
until i ever saw her
how did that come about
funny story um
so
uh after
mom disappears
dad really kind of thinks himself into
work uh because he's a single parent
he's got to do his thing
and so he really pushes himself and he
becomes
i mean i i mean i don't know how he did
it he was doing eight-hour days at work
coming home taking care of me and then
stayed up till like two or three in the
morning doing night school to just keep
getting more education more education
and he finally became like one of the
senior project managers of a major firm
here in atlanta uh where i live and
by the like 2000
one 2002 where you know the housing
market was going crazy and that was his
specialty he was doing those sun cities
those massive
uh housing complexes you know 100 home
kind of places
and he was he started to get phone calls
from people in like uh san jose and all
these places like hey you never heard of
us but we've heard of you what would it
take for you to come out to california
and i remember being in his office one
day for one of those calls and he i mean
i heard him distinctly say like
oh
i knew he was joking he's like oh he'll
take 150 000 pay my moving expenses and
set me up with an apartment
and they just said done
and i was like
dad are we moving to california and he's
like i think we are and so we do we
lived up
up near sacramento for
a while we lived there for about
four or five years okay and then we
moved to maryland because that's when
the recession kicked in i think it was
kind of a big wave that hit the country
and we just went as far away as the wave
as we could
so we landed in maryland kind of rode
that out and then i moved back to
california myself
uh met a girl
and we got married
and
at that point in time i was like hey
um let's see dad got laid off from his
engineering job and we both decided to
go in and start a remodeling business
because we that's what we we both know
that uh
industry very well
and
in a time where people can't sell their
homes what do they do they keep fixing
them up so they stay together that's
pretty common and so he's like well hey
if you move back
because we're moving back to georgia for
uh
they were doing it for several different
reasons if you move back here with us
we'll just do this company thing and
we'll just run i was like sounds great
you know i'm in my early 20s you know i
don't really have a particular career
path yet so
remodeling great yeah that's that's big
money let's go do that
so me and the girl i'm married we moved
to georgia
and
you know
i guess keep in mind you know through my
middle school high school and even out
of that any girl i met or dated or
whatever and i met their family
what's the first question what where's
your parents because i'm living in
california by myself where's your family
well my dad's you know wherever i don't
know where my mom is
and then you know the tirade of
questions about whatever
and so
we go let me ask my question here you
never bothered to even try to look her
up locator none of that you just didn't
give a [ __ ]
your dad as well
um i don't know about what dad did um
i
i think even at like an early age i
basically resigned myself to the idea
that if you don't give a [ __ ] about me i
don't give a [ __ ] about you mm-hmm
and and i know that sounds harsh
especially when you talk about your own
mother but it's like the more i kept
thinking about it it was like
wait a minute
you just ran off
no no i mean i'm talking
i'm talking no contact no christmas
cards no
birthday so i'm like you cut off all
contact with me i got nothing for you
you know if you want in touch with me
we'll talk if you're not
it we won't
so
i just kind of let it go and again i had
such good family and and and network of
friends
i didn't feel like there was anything to
it's like that what's that uh you don't
miss what you never had
you know i don't remember having a mom i
remember having a grandmother and an
aunt and a great-grandmother who were i
mean
so sacrificial and like right there for
me for anything i needed i was like i'm
good
i've got what i need you just
keep on doing you
so
once we got back to georgia my wife at
the time um
she kept kind of poking at it like hey
we're back in the south why don't you
look up your mom
i was like i don't want to i got no
desire i literally have no desire to
okay well why don't you look up your
siblings because they didn't do anything
to you i mean it's worth a shot nice
okay i'll look at my sister
and i found her um
what was she doing at the time i think
she was like a hairdresser or something
which
i don't know if there's a more southern
cliche of us
a hairdresser but that's what she did
and adam what was the i'm going to say
what the place is called people will
look it up um
but that's what she did and i found her
on facebook and
just kind of hit her up one day and i
was like
hey i don't know if you remember me or
not but i'm kind of your brother so i'm
kind of your brother
brother
you know our parents kind of [ __ ] at
one point so you know well i know it's
not true never mind your dad her dad
[ __ ] your mom right that's it
christian times that i don't ignore that
anyway but yeah so she
it's kirsten man don't make the mistake
i make it's cursed
that's right curse and i i sincerely
apologize uh kirsten time stamp that um
so uh i i hit her up and she and and
about a week she responded
um
you know hey how are you how you been
that kind of thing and how old are you
at this point
20
6. i didn't ask you the ques answers of
the questions at the beginning how old
are you right now
30 i'll be uh i'll be 32 in a month okay
so
latter part of 31. 26 how old's the
sister that you hit up is she older or
younger than you older okay every
everyone i have in my uh i mean i've got
uh step siblings right now everyone's
older than me okay i'm the youngest i'm
the youngest and yet in my steps i was
the first one to have a kid so that was
kind of funny okay but that's a whole
different thing so you look her up and
you connect
yeah very very slowly my sister had a
lot of trepidation about getting in
touch with me because i think she was
afraid that i always had a lot of
animosity or resentment built up towards
that side of the family which i i
genuinely didn't i was just kind of
doing it out of
i mean shits and giggles really because
i was i was asked to
um
and so we finally
back and forth back and forth and agreed
to
meet for dinner one night at a place in
up in chattanooga where she was living
and
got got to the restaurant she saw me and
you know she's just in tears i mean
she's just
and the way she explained it to me later
was that she felt like i was that
lost part of her life that she didn't
know if she'd ever get back because
because i mean he had no contact it was
it was really nice
um
and
but if your mom was a better person she
could have simply told her how to get a
hold of you or what easily
we we found out later uh my dad worked
in chattanooga for like about
eight months or a year or so right
before we moved to california
uh and we lived in an apartment complex
literally don't a mile no
a mile isn't it amazing that you could
do that for a year and never run into
tony hinchcliffe
yeah right
but you could never run into her at the
grocery store or any of that [ __ ] it's
crazy
no i i went as much as you bounced
around you guys did live a mile within a
mile of each other in for one full year
that's nuts
yeah and and genuinely if we hadn't
that and here's one if we had to move to
california
my sister and i would have went to the
same high school no
yeah whoa that would have been she would
have been a senior i'd have been a
freshman but yeah we would we would have
went to the same high school and not
even known it though right
uh
initially no not unless we would have
run into each other in the halls um
of course
i don't know if i'd have one or two
really anyway because the middle school
i went to up there
the building was over a hundred years
old
and
there was this apparent fun game that
kids like to play especially in the boys
bathroom where they would see how long
they could take a piss or a [ __ ] in the
toilets without flushing them
and just saw him man yeah but someone
ever left and i'm like
y'all this reeks yeah bamboo we're going
on 14 days don't touch it you're gonna
break the cycle i was like
i think it's an okay cycle to break guys
i mean my my nose is
uh you know i got a hair falling out
from ammonia smells it was it was
horrendous and i was like if that's
middle school i don't want to see what
the high school was because that
would've been
[ __ ] [ __ ] show but anyway
um
so i thought yeah so i found that out
later and you know and according to my
sister which i take her out of word she
was constantly probing my mom like
why aren't we in touch with him why
can't we talk to him why this why that
and never really got an answer we would
never get a straight answer probably a
bunch of you know roundabout [ __ ] so
take me back to the first meeting she
was really emotional and happy and you
find out that that she's been wanting
this connection
yeah i mean you're relieved i'm sure to
hear that
um
yeah i think so i mean you're not being
met with go [ __ ] yourself i'm not going
to tell you anything you know what i
mean you're being met with who the [ __ ]
are you yeah you're being met with man
i've been looking for you or asking
about you you know that's nice big
where have you been yeah and
and yeah and at that time she already
had four kids and so wow
she had just turned 30 i think 30 31
already had four kids
uh she was one of those um
uh panama city senior trip knock-up
[Laughter]
which i felt so bad for because she had
a scholarship to ut up in knoxville for
like a cheerleading scholarship and then
she comes out finds out uh whatever it
is how many weeks later after panama
city she's pregnant and has to basically
throw her entire college career away wow
she got knocked up i was like
that kind of okay okay man
but yeah
her and her husband are a trip um
but yeah she's like you're still in
touch you still communicate you're nope
no
no what how do you go from [ __ ] being
stoked
so
well
yeah i'll i'll jump ship on that one
right quick uh so
basically they wound up
okay
so the story we're going to get to they
bought that house okay that it takes
place in it was like one of their
grandparents houses that they passed
away they bought it for sentimental
reasons
that house needed like 80 grand worth of
remodels i mean like new plumbing new
electrical the whole thing it was built
like in the 60s
and hey your brother does
remodeling contracting work why don't
you call him
she didn't call me
didn't ask me for a quote didn't ask me
for nothing
wounds up hiring some bum handyman who
rips them off like takes
30 45 grand just and just runs and
doesn't do a little harder to do any
work
and
who does she call to clean up the mess
this guy
and i walked in i looked around at that
i said you you still need like another
80 90 grand a to fix what he messed up
and then b to do it right it was that
bad
he this guy
he did their tile backsplash in their
kitchen right and so when when he was
done with the grout and all the the
mortar for holding up the tiles what did
he do with it he goes to the bathroom
and dumps it down the shower drain no he
did not
oh yeah and [ __ ] up the pipes the all
of it the whole plumbing system is you
know because it's like a you know two
inch pipe and so that much of it is
covered in grout and it it looks like a
clogged artery i mean
it's awful
it's like somebody been in kfc for 40
years in their pipes it was [ __ ]
and so i'm like i'm sorry you're gonna
need and she apparently got the
impression that i was trying to like
get them out of money
and
wouldn't ever talk to me again
and just literally stop talking to me
like she likes i don't that's that was
the story i got from her she just
literally thought
oh oh you're just another one of those
contractor types and you're just
you're trying to take advantage of your
sibling and just make off with a bunch
of money and and i was like i was like
no that's just what it i'm sorry i'm
sorry what you saw on
the diy channel or hdtv but you can't
remodel a kitchen for five grand i'm
sorry that's just not how it works
so
it just became this whole thing and
gosh i've not talked to her now in
probably
two years
damn all right i
and i was constantly like holidays hey
happy easter happy thanksgiving happy
birthday our birthdays are 10 days apart
i'm like happy birthday no response
the last response i got was thanks
that was it and that was two years ago
and i said well [ __ ] you yeah i'm not
wasting my time just not
so but up to that point
it was great we hung out we did a bunch
of stuff and so
to get back to your point about when did
i first meet my mom again
uh one of my nieces does softball like
travel tournaments the full thing i mean
she goes all out travels all over the
country to play
at 12.
i don't understand that at all but um
we were at one of the they were at one
of the tournaments not far from where we
lived and she sent me a text and was
like hey you know so-and-so is playing
softball would you want to come watch
i played ball most of my life softball
too and i was like hell yeah i'd come
watch for sure
get up there
and it's one of those all day
tournaments too like get there at seven
in the morning they're able to find them
right
i'm like i ain't [ __ ] sticking around
for this i'll watch a game or two
but uh we get there and
it's it's my sister's husband it's me
and then her
and we're just kind of sitting there
watching we're talking or whatever and i
start noticing out the corner of my eye
my sister's i mean she's texting a lot
and kind of doing this shifty look
over at me while she's talking i'm like
do you ask her is mom going to be there
you don't nothing no because do you
think there's a chance going into this
no
nothing that thought never entered your
mind
no because we had talked about it uh uh
not not at that first meeting but it's
in in uh subsequent meetings we had
talked about it and she's like
how do you feel about talking to mom how
do you feel about getting re-entered i'm
just like i have no
i i don't not want to but i got no
desire to just you know go out of my way
so
we just kind of left it at that and so
she's kind of doing this whole thing and
and i can see her doing it but i'm not
going to like call her out i'm so i'm
just kind of watching the game and she
finally gets up and says um
i gotta run to the car and grab
something y'all i'll be right back and
so she just goes off and leaves
okay
keep watching the game
and my sister's husband finally kind of
looks over at me and he's just uh
so man um
you think you're gonna get in touch with
your mom
i don't know but you know we're just
that's all about it i just i don't know
if i'm if i'm quite ready to yet i don't
know if i care enough and he's like oh
okay
well
get ready
nah
what and he kind of give me one of those
nods that direction and i kind of look
up some [ __ ] if my mom and my sister
are not walking up the sidewalk at
towards us
i mean what are you feeling hand to
jesus
numb
absolute numbness
because
i see a face
that's my mother i know it's my mother
how pictures and stuff or you really
remember
i remember because there is a vhs tape
okay that i think my grandmother has
of a christmas
like 91 92
of my mom in it
now mind you this is 91 so she had
buzzed up sides really kind of curly i
mean it was very 90s
and i remember that face from that video
because i'd watched it a couple times
just to
i think i just did it just to remember
who my mother was because after
20-something years she kind of started
losing that thing
and um
i and of course she's aged you know not
not considerably but she has a little
bit but i know it's that's who it is and
do you look like her does she look like
you know do you resemble each other i
look my face looks like my grandfather
okay my hair is my mother my dad's side
of the family is black curly hair my
mom's side is
kind of wavy blonde
of course i got blue eyes from her as
well so everyone thinks i'm an aryan but
it's like no i'm just
scottish and a little bit of cherokee
and we just leave it at that
um
but but you know sure enough here she
comes with my sister and i can see my
sister's face and she i can tell she
thinks she [ __ ] up
because she feels that that tension
prove it and i'm like
what's your mom's face
is there a smile i don't care
i don't think genuinely my mother knew i
was there
you don't even think she knew
no i think my sister set this up
because she knew i think maybe in her
heart that neither one of us were going
to make that move
and she's like i gotta do something
about this i gotta i gotta
be nosy if nothing else
and so and i i and i could and the
reason i think that is because mom was
kind of looking at her and talking but
not really looking at me because i would
think if you see your son after
20-something years you're just staring
at him the whole way wasn't even looking
at my direction just
so she finally makes the turn around
around the uh home plate and how old how
old are you the last time you saw oh
five god five
yeah five and and here she comes from
the home plate behind the the backstop
and she looks up and sees me
and i'm i'm staring at her the whole way
hey [ __ ] sit down
[Laughter]
my grandfather if he was umpiring um no
but here she comes and
and she looked up made eye contact with
me and i made eye contact with her and
she stopped i mean dead cold in her
track just
saw me
and and my sister kind of like
yeah your sister don't know what to do
i'm talking the uh the uh the val kilmer
you know kind of like i'm your
huckleberry what's happening kind of
look
and and mom just kind of
and she and she kept coming
and so
she comes over to the bleachers and i
i see get up and i step down just
whatever
and
and we just kind of stood and looked at
each other for like
10 or 15 seconds just kind of sizing
each other up a little bit and she just
kind of
held her arms out for a hug
and
i was like
okay and so we had a hug
and what was that like
i hated it yeah
i hated it was it like hugging a
stranger or what was it like
or did it feel good and that's why you
hated it
no
no it felt
let's try to explain this in the
it felt like a betrayal to myself
man i know exactly what you mean you
know what i mean like it felt like i
gave
[ __ ] satan a hug or something like it
was just like
it's like the pope giving satan a hug
it's like i ain't supposed to be doing
this but
we're here so let's just whatever and so
we did and you know let go whatever and
she sat down beside me
and the one thing and i've talked to um
the the wife i moved back to georgia
with we split up and i'm with my current
wife and daughter and everything and our
life is monumentally better
but the one thing i talked to my current
wife about because her one thing we
bonded about was [ __ ] mothers
because her mom was just batshit crazy
um
kind of like yolo you know his mom yeah
that was very similar um
but uh she she told me herself her mom's
already passed and she said you know
when your mom passes you'll feel like a
part of you has died or you've lost
something
and
i was like
i don't know about that because
i just don't feel
that kind of rapport with my mom i don't
i mean you stuck around with your mom
your mom was around but she was a
[ __ ]
mama that [ __ ] hadn't just left i don't
know i don't know what you feel
um
but
and i remember her telling me that and i
remember saying to her i said well maybe
but the one thing i will always
um
hold against my mother uh and even to
this day she's not done anything she
never said sorry
she's never said sorry she's never
apologized for walking out even when we
sat down for the first time in 23 years
there was no
i [ __ ] up
my bad
you know i mean even something as simple
as that no it was just well hey how are
you
how's everything going you doing good
how's work everything's going good for
you okay great
she asked about your dad
no i don't believe she did i don't
remember asking about him um
she because she was at the time i think
maybe still biz she was with the guy
that she left my dad kind of left my dad
for
um well who she was seeing
when they got divorced because whenever
we'd go on some visitations we'd go up
to his house
and
i remember her dropping me off at his
house
and he he's an interesting guy he sells
taxidermy animals
like he goes to like africa
kills leopards cheetahs
whatever oh [ __ ] and sells yeah [ __ ] him
he's an [ __ ]
and
but i remember distinctly he would take
us to like gun and knife shows at trade
centers and that was his idea of
chaperoning us
[Laughter]
yeah yeah oh it was great that was great
and we i mean we'd go to like the the
whatever trade set the camp jordan arena
in chattanooga and he'd sit there and go
at 30 out six right there
that puts a big [ __ ] hole in the
cheetah's head i was like
what
and he's like
it makes you get your real sharp knife
you gotta he starts like telling us how
to like skin an animal i'm like
i'm gonna say his name i'll call him uh
we'll call him sean i'm like sean i
don't care
i'm five yeah i'm not gonna skin an
animal maybe a squirrel but a cheetah
no
but um
anyway so so
we we just sat there and chatted for
like
i don't know 10 or 15 minutes what what
stands out the most in that 15-minute
conversation to you
no regret
that she showed absolutely
no regret
about her decision
does it hurt you to know
that she had a child that she kept and
loved and everything you know that she's
literally capable of being a mom
to those okay to those three kids it's
not like she's [ __ ] to all four of her
children
she's [ __ ] to one me yes um so does it
[ __ ] with you to know that this person
had parenting in them and just decided
you weren't yes you did i think you need
to [ __ ] quit
can you shut the [ __ ] up about that
nonsense that's what i do man that's
what i do
we're here to highlight the low lights
baby
not pants nation tour
though cincinnati ohio january 22 the
22nd let's keep the city sorry
i don't know what it is i get all my
dates all run together ain't coming to
[ __ ] atlanta i know that i'll be
where i'm working on it you better
[ __ ] come
um
we just won the world series you better
get down here you sure did
um so anyway but uh yeah there was no
and that was no regret no remorse no
regret she the the two biological kids
from her first husband she
kept and loved and held on to and then
the guy she left my dad for he had a son
her now her stepson who she just open
armed and and that was it and i found
out later when her when shawn her then
husband would go on these trips across
the world to get animals he would take
her and they would take the kids with
them
so all my other siblings have been
to africa south africa thailand across
the world doing all this stuff that i'm
just
like
okay cool uh i'm going to dollywood
[ __ ] yes
yes going to dollywood i'm gonna sink
gonna go the dixie stampede and sing
those racist anthems good god
uh
no my dad i i've got on i'll brag on him
a little bit he
went out of his way that whole time like
when it was just me and him to
make sure it did not feel empty
uh i mean like even at like
we were nine years i was nine years old
and we drove to toronto to go to the
hockey hall of fame because i was in i
was huge into hockey for several years
and then i turned 12
and
i'm huge into music and then what does
he do he just books a trip and we drive
to the rock and roll hall of fame in
cleveland that's cool yeah and and
uh we actually have this tradition uh my
hat says it all we go to pikes peak in
colorado every 10 years up to the top
and take a picture because we we lived
in colorado springs when he was in the
army and we just when i was one he took
a picture we were 11 and so on we just
did it a few weeks ago
and it takes me to california you know
and then
i was in the boy scouts as a kid and
through his military connections he gets
us into like kings bay georgia naval
base and gets us tours on like nuclear
submarines and all this while i mean
it's it's
it's amazing the stuff that he was able
to do
uh
on a shoestring budget i mean
poor's as a single parent too you know
think about all you're able to do with
two of you
it's a lot
yeah he's him and my family are just a
marvel to me and i i
could never thank him enough for
everything they've done
but um
he sounds he sounds awesome now tell me
about your mom trying to [ __ ] you
so your dad's cool
not cool enough how's mom doing
how's him titties look
yeah your dad's like i love you know how
she was
okay so we'll we'll circle around to
that
so so wait let's go back real quick you
have this conversation you sit there 15
minutes so what happens after that like
as far as the two of you go do you do
you communicate do you what happens next
yeah mom got the phone number and so
we're we're texting not like super
regularly but maybe once a week every
odds and then
and i'll distinctly remember
the the text you sent me after that yeah
we hung out for maybe 15 maybe 20
minutes and then i just felt too weird
and i left i was like i'm going back
home i just
i don't know because we cannot sit in
silence for like 10 minutes it's like
i'm just gonna go home i i can't do this
so i did that and she sent me a text
later that evening was like
gosh it was great to see you i i love
that you're doing well and that you've
gotta you're starting a family just
skipping over 23 years just right to
then and just it's great
like church lady it's so wonderful yeah
you just have a wonderful life let's
just talk about this go from we're
jumping up from kindergarten to now we
have nothing's existed yeah like nothing
ever happened and so
we kind of put it along put it along and
so
uh
that was like april of that year
i get a text in june from my sister
that says hey just a heads up um
at the house and they that they bought
and kind of screwed me out of money for
they're like hey at this house
we hold a big fourth of july party
every year and we got a pool trampoline
we can invite everybody in the family
who's close by to come up and we just we
blow it out and just have a big old time
because they're kind of up on a mountain
so they can do fireworks and the whole
thing
that's like
like yeah okay you know and up to that
point nothing weird had happened you
know we're all pretty
amicable
um
and so we met my wife at the time we go
up there
and
i think we got there maybe about four or
five in the afternoon
and
it's not just family
at this place
uh it's not anybody i know anyway
and and we kind of get there and you
know it's it's one of those just
rednecks things there's cars in the yard
and there's a motor hanging from the
tree i mean it's a really
sketchy looking thing and we but we roll
in and we're like okay and we find get
in the house i find my sister just to
let her know we're there if nothing else
and i was like hey you know
it's an awful lot of people here i mean
is this is this really family and she
she gives me that look like she's
already in a mood
and i was like what's going on
she's like
she's like you've never met mom's alter
ego
i was like
mom's alter ego
and she's like yeah um
i mean you hardly ever met mom
we're going to meet mommy you know
we're going to learn some differences
here
and so
she's like
come in the background with me i got
some stuff i got to talk to you about
okay
and so we get back in there and she's
like okay you gotta know just right now
mom's an alcoholic
mom does coke
mom he starts laying this mom does this
mom does that mom hosts orgies mom does
this she's just whoa oh yes like just
laying this heavy stuff out on me and
like mom's already had like four duis
she's she's in court all the time trying
to get this stuff worked out
i'm like
okay but why are you telling me all this
and she's like
okay
mom has an alternative personality when
she gets really drunk
and
i won't say her actual name but her
alternative name her alternative ego
name is vicky
and when vicky shows up
it's a [ __ ] show
it's it's anything can happen
uh
you just need to hold on tight and and
just ride through it i was like
okay fine
i'm like is is vicky here now you know i
thought i was talking to like a somebody
like a a possessed person yeah yeah yeah
it's vicky yeah we talked to her um and
she's like she's like no vicki vicki's
not here yet but
she said mom did i email you that
picture of of the the alcohol bottles i
think you may have yeah yeah i did yeah
uh if you if you find that and look at
it again that was like one of vicky's
weekends
where you know it's like
six smearing off bottles and just i mean
it's just a
mound of bottles the empty bottles
um
and i was like she's like well no
vicki's not here yet but but she's
coming
like mom's already poured through a
handle of jack and she's already on a
thing of patron vicki's coming
so
if you stay if you go it's up to you i
was like
i looked at my then wife was like what
do you think she and and she was um
where she went to uc sonoma
uh and she's like i was in a
sorority
i did frat parties we're good like well
well i was like okay
and so we got into it and and whatever
and
at the time when we showed up
there was probably
35 people at the house
well as vicki
started a churning
she started calling people
hey
i'm up the house we're having a party
you should come up
byob by the way do your own thing
so i just start noticing more and more
cars start pulling up in the driveway
in about two hours it was a it was we
counted about 200 people
holy [ __ ]
200 people vicki had connections i was
gonna say i don't know i'd love to get
i'd love to be able to pick up a phone
get 170 people out to a [ __ ] stand-up
show
let me get vicky or maybe vicky should
do my [ __ ] marketing hey if if you do
chattanooga vicky will show up and bring
some [ __ ] to your
show give me five leave it
vicky you here let's roll um
but yeah so
so she i mean it was like yeah 200
people
and it's not
just friends i mean these are people
that she would meet in bars that she
would meet with these
really divey the kind of people you go
to the bathroom and you do stuff that's
illegal in four states i mean yeah
one guy walks out with a saddle and a
set of jumper cables and you don't know
what just happened in that bathroom
and but it's these kind of folks and you
can tell some of them are tweakers some
of them are just drunks and i mean it's
a wild menagerie of folks
but the one person who showed up
who should not have showed up is um
what do we call her we'll call her maria
maria showed up
uh who was mom's kind of um alter alter
ego
her wing woman kind of situation
but uh maria i almost said her name uh
maria's uh m.o
at any party bar house whatever
she's a [ __ ] stir
and you know those people at a party
that all they want to do is show up you
know say the right thing hey a bit of a
rumor here a bit of a thing there so and
so said something about you and just
what's it um that'll you remember that
old dane cook joke where he talked about
[ __ ] on coats at a party
i don't remember now
he had this great joe i mean it's one of
his first albums like oh three but he
had this joke where he was like if you
ever want to leave your mark on people
what you need to do is show up at a
party whether it's someone's fancy
parties where there's coats and a coat
check go in the room with all the coats
[ __ ] on the coats
and then you leave don't say anything
and then somebody comes in and discovers
there's [ __ ] on the coats and then your
role is just creep in right quick and go
hope it's not on my coat and then you
slip out again and you don't do anything
but that's the kind of person she was
she'd go in and [ __ ] on someone's coat
and then just wait for someone to find
it and just kind of go oh
someone [ __ ] on your coat
that's wild i wonder who i probably todd
your todd's been eyeing that coat you
know that's all she would do
and so
this particular instance uh
she decided that she was going to play
bartender
for the entire party
and in the kitchen kind of having those
little islands that kind of jutted out
into the thing it was pretty wide
kitchen
and
when people would show up they would
just bring bottles of stuff you know so
this whole island is getting filled up
with jack daniel's patron bacardi just
i'm not handles of stuff
no one's bringing beer they're just
bringing liquor i don't know what i mean
that's a southern thing a beer is for
[ __ ] i don't know what this is about
but it's like here it comes and i i
would sort of swing by and i'll just
slowly watch this thing grow and here
she is just like got a sink and she's
making white russians and you know
orange juice and vodka and screwdrivers
all that kind of stuff
so
as it as i found out later um
there were a couple guys that vicki had
invited to the party that she was trying
to get with that particular even she was
just on a tear and thought well you know
this is the night i'm going to get in
you know
teddy loon's pants or something you know
we're
getting teddy's pants that beard pie
turned her on man he's from now he's
from chicago the south side you got him
no detroit he's from detroit
watch out for that man he'll get you
that old that old uh little crow
training
one of my favorite one life
just a weird reaction
where's my staple gun at i'm trying to
finish a gazebo god damn
anyway
but she's trying to get in this a couple
guys pants or whatever that evening and
so um
her wing woman decides
uh and again another one of her um
uh
proclivities is to spike drinks
not like
not really roofie somebody to where you
black out you know what's happened but
she would put something to this day i
don't know what it was
in drinks that would kind of make you a
little loopy a little loose-headed and
you just would kind of go with the flow
and see what happened
so
she knew what guy's mom was after which
i think was like two guys in particular
and she's like okay well there and she
would keep keeping eye on them okay
they're drinking whiskey tonight so
i'll be you know
the good bartender and kind of keep oh
you're empty here's another drink here's
another drink just kind of keep
everybody well uh well lubricated
and so
she
she saw the one guy and was like hey
you're out
hold on
you know the drink you go he's oh great
appreciate it and i remember and he's
like
hang on i need to go to the bathroom so
he sets his drink down on the bar
and goes to the bathroom
i'm also drinking whiskey that night
because that's just what i drink
i come up to the bar and i'd already had
a few but i was
my sister they kind of told us earlier
on that you know hey if you need a crash
here you're set there's like five or six
bedrooms
you're good
okay so i get to the bar and i see this
full drink just ready to go and i'm
thinking
dave there she is drinks are ready and
she's just making them like take what
you want right here we go
no idea what was happening so i grab it
and i'm not
i don't nurse drinks really like i'm you
know if i want to get a an effect let's
get it going
um
and and i down this drink pretty
pretty quick and so
my uh then wife later recalled to me she
said you know it it took about 20
minutes
and and you didn't look like you were
doing okay like you were just kind of
really rocking in your chair you're
looking around like everybody was weird
and i don't remember much of it at first
and she finally said you know hey why
don't you just go on the back bedrooms
lay down and just kind of
collect yourself and come on back out in
a few minutes or whatever
yeah okay i'll go do that and so i
apparently get up i go to the bedroom
well a bedroom i don't know which one
and and lay down and i just kind of you
know spread eagle on the bed just
watching the world kind of
sway and move in and out and not really
know what's happening
i kind of pass out
i don't know for how long i never i
never did ask that but
the next thing i remember
was kind of an a commotion
and
this weight
kind of on my like stomach midsection
uh
are you cheating on your wife with your
mother
my mother's trying to get me to cheat on
my
you man you jumped the plot what are we
doing ryan god jesus
so
i opened my eyes
and but it's still kind of hazy you're
not sure what's happening
and all i see in front of me is just
this pair of tits
i mean tits are out
hips are out
i mean i'm talking not maybe six or
eight inches from my face i mean it's
just tits and my first rick my cognitive
thought is
oh my wife's trying to do a little
something something while we're here
all right let's see
and i and i'm slowly trying to like
collect myself to get myself in that
head oh yeah and i start feeling my belt
buckle kind of get fiddled with you know
that kind of like first of all your mom
already took her titties out and your
belt is not she's not even got you
undressed yet she is ready to go
now in all fairness the room is dark it
don't matter
your mom's ready to go your mom's ready
to go
so
and i'm getting i'm just kind of like
well dang girls get ambrose let's let's
see what happens
the next thing i know is i just hear the
door wham slam open
and i the lights go on and you like kind
of feeling when you're dark from light
you're kind of stunned for a minute and
i kind of look over and i see
my sister
and my wife over her shoulder oh my just
like
what the [ __ ] is happening
in this room mate you may have never
been in a fraternity sorority party like
this have you
this is american pilot oh my god
and she was on the prowl
so
i i don't know admittedly i don't see my
my mother
i just look over and see her and i hear
her yell is what the [ __ ] are you doing
and i'm like wait there's her and my
wife
who the [ __ ] and i look up and
it's my mother
just with her kitties out with the
titties out
holy [ __ ]
that's nice
and she's looking at my sister already
she ain't looking down at me i look up
at her
i'm like
oh
well
and she and
mom
uh i recall mom saying and she's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing in here get
out
she's not done man
and my sister goes do you realize who
you're trying to [ __ ]
and kind of points at me and she's like
yeah steep
and kind of sees me and goes
well that's not who i expected
but um
i'm just here to get laid no
that's what your mom said
i'm just here to get laid
my god
[Music]
the lights are wrong
and more and more people are slowly
you know starting the cars what the
[ __ ] going on back there with vicky
nicki you done yet my turn
holy [ __ ]
oh yeah full on just like i'm shooting
what do you do
i'm i'm paralyzed i don't know what to
do because immediately my head's not all
there yet
i'm still reeling from whatever
maria put in drinks i'm like is that my
mother
that's my mother
what
what's happening here
and
my sister's like you're trying to [ __ ]
your son what or what's in your head now
immediately when she's in vicki mode
she's gone she's four sheets of the wind
there's there's no there's no mom left
up here it's vicki
and she's just like
a bunch of spoil sports and gets up off
me puts her shirt back on buttons it and
just out the door
leaving me
you know built undone just in a in a
tussle like
okay
well that just happened
and so
my my then wife
i mean she's in
shock is an understatement yeah she's
poor she's thinking this is when i'm
jerry's your erection's not helping the
case either
you know
[ __ ] a temp pull up [ __ ] with a flag
pole man
you look a good candy man
what is she saying what is it
[ __ ] quiet
exactly we listened to a lot of
[ __ ] gordon lights
let's play the bee gees the slogan
oh my god
yo it was mmm that was a very but and
then off no she handled it actually i
guess as best as you could because she
realized my sister later explained
like
basically what had happened was
the dude my mom was trying to go after
walked down the same hallway as the
bedrooms
in vicki mode she's under the impression
that he's giving her like a you know
let's go to the back bedroom he was also
going to the toilet
so he's already four doors past where i
am and in the bathroom and she kind of
creeps up and thinks he's in that
bedroom
gets in and thinks that's who she's with
and
that's great and all but
when you just say i'm just here to get
laid and you're laying on top of your
sign
there's some confusing uh messages that
get sent with that
but there it is but so once my sister
explained all that to us um
my wife was
not cool about it but she was a lot more
understanding about um
what had just taken place
and and we didn't even stay the night
like
no [ __ ] weight was standing there
it's like bates motel in that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] get out somebody's getting laid
in there i know that that's hotel
california you know my god jesus
so we finally split uh we got i got up
collecting myself and i looked at my
then wife i said are you okay to drive
and she's like i am now
like i wasn't five minutes ago yeah i i
don't know adrenaline does something to
you
i was like yeah it does
and so we we left and went home uh that
and we wouldn't and we didn't hear from
anybody from that side of the family for
probably
that was july probably until october
um
and about
close to halloween my sister
contacted me and she said um
you know
we've kind of talked through things with
mom and kind of explained a lot to her
and she she either didn't remember or
you know whatever in her state
um
i'm gonna give a quick side side story
about mom
sh you know she i mean she's she's an
i've seen that picture she's an
alcoholic she's just full-blown yeah
she tries to go to rehab fails the whole
thing
the last time i was told about her
relapse
she got so drunk she called the cops on
herself
she she was at a bar
got there at 11 a.m left at nine p.m
holy [ __ ] tried to drive herself home
made it i think it was about a half a
mile maybe three quarters a mile away
from the bar pulled into a rite aid
parking lot called the cops
and i heard the message instead of just
sleeping there in the car you could have
just slept there in the car not vicki no
no
uh she called the car and they played
the the the tape back in court because i
actually went to that hearing
she
uh her call called to the ems and i
wonder what it was hey you need to get
somebody out here there's some crazy
[ __ ] out here driving swerving like
there ain't nobody's business and it's
going to kill somebody if y'all ain't
careful well ma'am where is she she's
right now she just pulled off into the
rite aid parking lot and she's in like a
grave ford taurus
okay
we'll be right there police are on their
way thank you click
the cops find mom in the grave iv taurus
with her seat back passed out they've
got to bust out the window drag her out
get her to the hospital they take her
blood
her
bac was
one nine holy [ __ ]
that's double
double
that's more than that that's more it's
almost that's like belushi level like
that's that's keith moon get you killed
oh my god and and so anyway that was
[ __ ]
one of those stories but anyway
so uh
sister called up she said whatever
mom feels real bad about everything
she wanted to know if you guys would
come for thanksgiving
i was like
is vicky going to be yeah
vicky maria is carl is anybody else
going to say no it's family
it's a thing i said
let me think about it i'll go back with
you she's okay and so i talked to my
wife and everything else she's like
if it's just family okay we'll try it
it's okay
so
mom was gonna have thanksgiving uh the
guy she left my dad for she's since
divorced so she's not actually married
to anybody
right now that i know of
uh at least a couple years ago
but she still lives with him because
he's kind of like he's one of those like
ostrich in the sand kind of people he
just sticks his head in he don't want to
know about problems he don't care
he's
loaded with money so he just puts money
in her paypal account and she just goes
nuts and spends and does whatever
so it's at his house up in the mountains
north of chattanooga so from where i'm
living at the time it's about a two-hour
drive
to that house
uh
i want to thank we were probably
five minutes away
i get a phone call from my sister i
answer the phone hey what's up vic you
got here
vicky showed up before you did no
veronica showed up this time
uh
she's like where are you at i was like
gps has about five minutes away from the
house why
don't bother
don't bother
yeah i just got a phone call from the
fire chief
mom apparently was day drinking since 9
00 a.m
this was like four or five in the
afternoon it's like thanksgiving evening
so it's like it's like it's like five in
the evening at that point
she's like yeah she started drinking at
nine this morning she tried to cook
a couple batches of hawaiian sweet rolls
and set the [ __ ] house on fire no
i was like
i'm sorry what on thanksgiving
on thanksgiving i mean
[ __ ]
carl griswold i mean they ain't got
nothing on this
i mean i was like
what do you mean the house is on fire
she's
she she she's like i don't know what to
tell you i'm telling you what i'm told i
mean she went in had been
drinking just bottles of vodka at this
point i mean like two or three bottles
in
and tried to cook hawaiian street rolls
and that and what killed me was she put
the sweet rolls in at three o'clock
that's all she had cooked
there was no green beans
no sweet potatoes
nothing no [ __ ] turkey
no no [ __ ] a turkey we ain't doing that
we're getting [ __ ] quarter pounders
from mcdonald's
turkey
and she's like yeah mom mama did that
she passed that on the the sofa recliner
things get something caught on fire and
now half the house is on fire she said
don't bother all right so let me wrap
this up here because i have this
question to ask you
is the last time you saw your mom the
time she had her titties out in your
face
it is that's the last time
that is the lingering uh picture in my
head yes
is it poor
but then mom started trying to blow up
my phone trying to talk to me trying to
do all my it's like nope
no
i'm not gonna do it and uh i've not
talked to her since
uh because i i met my now current wife
and and i could not be happier i've got
a three-year-old with her
and i made a decision i was like you're
not going to be around my kid
like you you do not have your [ __ ] yeah
you can be
no cannot you can't yeah
there's nothing about you
or
just that side of the family in general
that
is any benefit to my kid it just isn't
and i'm not going to
i mean good god she's got me as a father
she's gonna have enough therapy as it is
when she gets older i mean all she's
gotta do is listen to this episode jesus
christ dude i hope by this time this
episode is just dissolved and gone into
history by the time she gets old enough
to know what i'm talking about and
that's the thing she's not going to know
who i'm talking about yeah that's the
weird thing
you know and i i kind of i've always
wondered that about what with you and
stella is like with your mom it's like
she's no she's met my mom yeah she knows
her now but she does she asks me about
my mom when we were i was a kid and i'm
like well grandma wasn't around she's
like what do you mean i'm like
i try to make sense of it but when it
doesn't make sense it's hard to make
sense to someone else not at that age
and even most
uh older people that i talked to when i
was you know in high school and trying
to explain my mom like
they couldn't grasp yeah because they've
never
experienced that no couldn't understand
like how a mother even mom you've never
had your mom's titties in your face not
when you were breastfeeding not in your
20s no i haven't met well dude thank you
so much for coming on and sharing this
story this is really uh
this is i mean unfortunate for you and
very fortunate for all of us to have
here heard that man
i want to gush for just a hot minute and
say
uh man i've been listening to you for
since crab face days loved everything
you do and
there's there's such a service you
provide doing this kind of thing for
people because i don't really obviously
i don't talk about this to a lot of
people but
um
just be it i wouldn't either i would not
i wouldn't no let's let's keep this on
the d on the low low lights let's just
keep that in the basement and where
michael lives uh but no i mean man you
you do
you do such a work and i i don't i don't
think you you really understand the
greatness
and and just the the prominence you hold
in a lot of people's lives by allowing
them to really vent if nothing else you
know i mean i'm i know you probably
don't consider yourself like a therapist
in any uh sense of the word but i mean
you really kind of are
you know
i listen to a lot of even like the
famous people you know even tom segura
burt uh
down to you know yola people people may
not know about them but it's like you
let people get their bear their souls
and let such a weight off of themselves
by just
you know
having somebody else they can fight in
in a way and now i think that's such a
tremendous
uh mental step for a lot of people into
getting recovery and getting better you
know don't hide stuff don't you don't
keep it to yourself no matter how
shameful you think it is don't be
embarrassed don't be whatever because i
promise you even with my story that you
probably never have heard i promise you
there's somebody else whose mom [ __ ]
them whose mom actually [ __ ] he did
yeah yeah
yeah who actually got balls deep in
their mind yeah that's what i'm thinking
well thank you for saying that it means
the world to me and if uh if you could
allow your mom to bear her tits i can
let you bear your soul so thank you zach
i appreciate you coming
some crabs together with the green
turtle
you know the spots bro you know
i'm with you man thank you i don't see
you in atlanta though when i book it i'm
we're we got dates still coming we got
all 20 22 i'm coming not pants nation
baby thank you brother and thank all of
you out there as well again if you're in
for the long haul sign up for a year get
over a month free if you've got that
story that has to be told please submit
it to honeydewpodcast at gmail.com
and uh thank you all for your support
come see me on tour get your tickets at
ryansickler.com
talk to you all next week
[Music]
you